- Did you ever get into
like, fantasy games?
Like Dragons and, Dungeons & Dragons,
is that what it's called?
- I never, well.
- I always have men on this
show that love that game.
- You know, I love the,
no, I didn't, I had, well,
back when I was in high
school, I was, I, (chuckles)
I did, there was Dungeons &
Dragons, which was a big thing.
It still is.
- I didn't know it was a big thing,
but I've had several actors,
like men on here, was like,
yeah, I'm in a club.
- Yeah.
- I'm like, what?
- I never got into that
kind of role playing thing.
But I wanted to be part of this group.
And then they said, yeah,
we're gonna play this,
and then we're gonna smoke
a bit of weed, we get high.
And I said, I don't
smoke, I can't do that.
So, they baked this cake for me.
(Kelly gasps)
And I like cake.
- I love this story.
- So, it came in,
and they were doing stuff.
And I just saw this cake,
and I just assumed it was
all for me, so I ate it all.
- No!
- And then, they came in
and said, where's the cake?
And I said, well, it
was for me, wasn't it?
And they go, you ate all of?
That's a lot.
And I'm like, no, it's gonna be fine, oh!
(audience laughs)
- It was weed cake?
It was, it had weed in it?
- It had like hash, hash,
whatever you call it, yeah.
(audience laughs)
- Weed but hash, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
I got a little weird.
- I bet you got really
(audience laughs)
into role playing.
(Kelly laughs)
- I did, I actually
literally, (laughs)
(Kelly laughing)
- Oh my God.
- I got into character
better than ever before.
I was literally
(Kelly laughing)
chasing my friends through the forest.
And they were like.
- Oh my God.
- Stop it and like, gah.
And I don't know what the
character was, but it was intense.
Then, we came back to the house,
and I remember I was crying
at one point.
(audience laughs)
(Kelly laughing)
And then, it was laughing and.
- The range of emotion.
- And then, they said
I suddenly fell asleep.
It was literally like, ah.
(audience laughs)
- Oh my God.
You ate the whole cake.
- I ate the whole cake.
- Oh, and you didn't know,
that's not good, Nikolaj.
(Kelly laughing)
- No, it's not good.
- That's a funnier, though.